So let's dig a little deeper into
what we mean by the Happened Before Relationship.
I'm going to denote the Happened Before Relationship
with this arrow. A happened before B. That's
what this notation means. What this notation is implying is one of two things,
either A and B are events in the same process which means given a belief that
a process is sequential A must have happened before
B. If it was a textual order A is here
and B is here then A must have happened
before B and that's one possibility. Or if you're asserting
that A happened before B and A and B are not events on the same process but A is
an event in one process, B is an event in
a different process. Then there must be a communication event
that connects A and B. In other words, if A is a communication event of a
message, and B is a receipt of that
same message. Then, A happened before B, where
A is the sender of the message and B is the receiver of the message. So,
this is the implication of saying that an
event in a distributed system A happened before B,
and these events can be anywhere in the system.
Anywhere in the system an event could be happening
A, and another event could be happening B, and
if we are asserting that A happened before B, what
we are implying is one of these two possibilities.
One is that A and B are events in the
same process or A is the act of a
sending a message and B is the act of receiving
a mess, the same message on a different
node of the distributed system. The other property
of the happened before relationship is that it
is transitive. What I mean by that is,
if we're asserting that there is an event
A that happened before B. And this event
B happened before C. The implication is this
relationship is transitive ad therefore A happened before C.
So that's the transitivity of the
Happened Before Relationship. Now that I introduced
to you the Happened Before Relationship it is time for another fun quiz.